the three main reasons companies go to
business the first one is they solve no
known problem which I think gets back to
the do as well as today where people are
investing in cool technology let's say
crypto or nfts are current examples they
solve no known problem blockchain okay
great another Ledger nothing new so a
lot of money goes towards that the next
reason they go to business is they don't
raise enough money and then the third
reason is they raised too much money
look at all the uh we're calling death
of corns I don't know if that's a word
we made up or yeah I give me that one up
yeah death Accord so like okay death
accordin so all these companies that
raised $100 million last year they're
going out of business it's like yeah
what the hell kind of governance is that
I I don't I don't understand business is
really simple you find a big problem you
solve it better than anyone else and
good things happen you know people give
you money and if you do a really good
job they give you a lot of money and
then you get this thing called profit